[Musique]
ça fait des semaines et souhaite que je
l'attends celui-ci est qu' il est là il
est là ça va ponctionner d'amour moi
super content de te voir c'est quoi on
s'est rendu compte que ton disque était
déjà en vente sur le site de petites
annonces
je te propose d'essayer de négocier ton
propre disque à ces normes
tu me laisses commencé mais c'est la
présente mal je te demanderai ton est à
cannes alors oui mais soit bonsoir
robert toi mon toit où les romains qui
est à la traîne alors romain c'est cyril
hanouna on est en direct sur ces huit
touche pas à mon poste hanouna n'ont pas
du tout la blague c'est montiel la scène
où la roma roma je t'appelle parce que
j'ai vu que tu avais mis le cd de
vianney en vente
oui oui pourquoi oui à 10 euros pourquoi
10 euros pour eux tu veux le vendre
d'accord mais et david lebon bien j'ai
monté à paris est ma copine m'a quitté
et je voulais au nom non vous vous allez
l'écouter l'eau et les il est bien de
céder d'y aller quand même
c'est ma copine équipage la merde oui je
suis un tweet choix je serais intéressé
par nsn la montée installé là bas si une
assiette qui projetait donc je vous ai
très bien votre cd de bernay parce qu'en
fait on a les romains sécher en fait je
suis vianney donc 6e
moi si j'ai pas d'idée vexé que tu vends
mon album je comprends un peu mieux oh
j'ai les boules pour toi mon pote et si
je peux faire un tête pour tu récupères
ta copine si ça peut aider
je suis là mon gars tu étais tu es una
toi tu pas que tu es loin des loin du
plateau là non avant son plateau la mine
à john catoe c'est de venir tout de
suite way romain au maillet là
quand vous regardez les animaux les
petits manu le faire respirer ça donne
autre chose que ça il bat des flancs
avec les pâtisseries
je rassure les gens qui m'ont dit ban
dès flore en avoir bavé flanc il creuse
et puis quand le vent sera fini
d'exposer leur vie donc on est très
stressé en fait on tire pour inspirer et
quand on est très très détendue on
pousse pour expliquer et on laisse
l'inspiration d'accord alors chat qui
ronronne et pousse alex pire et ça
démontre un dernier petit exerce un rôle
chez vous il ya moyen de faire des
mouvements alors qu'il favorise pas si
la france en est là c'est bien un qui va
vous plaire alors si c'est ça pour se
calmer un petit peu d'abord c'est le
souffle dure à prendre enfin avec
l'élastique
syrine regarder ça vous plaît d'accord
on sait quand on inspire en mettant les
points sous les épaules une fois qu'on
est là où tu en faisais un grand
attention s'est posé la question qu'est
ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on diffuse
l'intervention de emmanuel macron tout
ça et je me suis dit oui mais non oui
mais non oui mais non pourquoi
ravi qu'on propose autre chose parce que
tu as on va savoir ce qu'il va dire oui
à un moment on n'est pas dans la pampa
non mais c'est vrai chez les coiffeurs
suite ouvert on le saura non mais c'est
vrai voilà donc je me suis dit autant
faire une autre proposition
contre-programmation je me suis dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer
dakar 3 ans d'efforts ailleurs barca on
connaît nos médias et en arca voilà j'ai
réussi mon conseil de défense
qu'ils soient là et on a pris la
décision de ne rien faire nathan
et là je me suis dit les règles qui vont
me regarder entre 20h10 d'accord makrout
va parler l'annuelle makrouds pas parler
et le moment où on a pu parler c'est
vraiment les gars s'en fout vraiment un
gros coup droit
je vois tu m'entends pas mal de mer de
faire pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent pour vraiment réactive et tout
ça pour vraiment voilà qu'on se dise
arriver là où la bourgogne c'est à dire
avec sa personne par exemple voilà il ya
un truc tout con
vraiment je vous le dit chez vous
vraiment par exemple ça on évite on
évite comment on adore mon et c'est
vraiment le confinement plus le gars car
il comme ça là c'est sûr que là sans
faire directement dans la salle de bain
la fesci la radio ça vous a beaucoup
appris j'adore la radio moi c'est un
média qui par son immédiateté avec avec
l'info c'est moins lourd on n'a pas les
images on n'a pas le traitement de
l'image qui sert aussi que je pense que
j'ai appris que j'ai adopté mais c'est
vrai que la radio c'est un média que
j'adore on m'a souvent dit que j'avais
une voix de radio écoutée et voilà
j'aime beaucoup ce média alors je
préfère nintendo mais je trouve dans cet
hymne d'amour je pas ce que vous en
pensez
je trouve que ça va pas il manque un
truc il manque un truc est ce qu'on peut
appeler josé s'il vous plaît
josé mon ami josé super c'est bien assez
merci merci procès du manque quelque
chose sur cette interview avec talent
eh oui parizeau bien oui à l'époque vous
saviez déjà vous voulez faire de la télé
on faisait de la radio je savais que
jouer de journaliste je sais pas je
voulais faire de la télé mais je suis
super heureux de voir procès qui fait
bien le débat qui avec 100 bien essaye
de suivre le rythme parce qu'on a un
sujet dimanche sur le mexique
ah bah voilà ça c'est l'amérique 2007 à
vis de bien sûr et mon pote voilà j'ai
pensé beaucoup à toi hier aujourd'hui
aussi je sais que tu as été extrêmement
touché bien sûr par la disparition de
christophe dominici d'abord merci de lui
rendre hommage
je crois qu'il le mérite mais j'adore ce
joueur c'est un génie parce que ici je
suis venu j'ai refusé toutes les télés
sus venu parce que d'abord c'est peu
d'émissions de sport et que ça m'a
touché je me suis dit il faut que tu y
ailles merci bernard fait de lui je
crois qu'une fois c'était c'était mon
devoir s'y passait c'est difficile à
caser parce que parce que c'était tout
ce que j'aime c'est et la rage justice
était de mise à niveau c'est que tu
l'avais dans une équipe saliver toujours
mais il était généreux et c'est pour ça
que j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est que
cette fin de vie doit laisser de ce soir
julia qui repart avec semble
[Applaudissements]
post 1 boîte inquiète pas voler la
croatie quoi ta boîte parmi des deux
mois j'ai manqué mon chéri tu marches
voir lalalala l'oseille lala dans les
prochains jours mais gérer l'espace
depuis tout à l'heure il aavait sur
plateau y regarde de plus à l'heure et
oui c'est sûr les 100 mm merci michel
d'être là merci beaucoup
et merci m afida et laly d'être là merci
beaucoup
alors michel on va revenir à ce soir du
21 novembre
vous arrivez dans votre local dans le
xviie arrondissement de paris
bon bah je rentrais dans les studios et
quand j'ouvre la porte pour entrer à
hauteur de mon studio
je sens une présence on a vu les images
donc très vite il ya un des policiers je
vois qui commença à vous agresser oui
est-ce qui vous demande quelque chose
qui vous disent vos skis vous demande
vos papiers
est-ce qu'il vous demande si vous ne
provenait pas de masquer ce qu'ils
essaient de discuter que vous ou direct
il vous agresse
non c'est très agressif tout de suite là
tout de suite je me prends des ta gueule
parce que j'essaye de savoir qu'est-ce
qui se passe jusqu'à aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils me reprochent
je sais pas ce qui me reprocher c'est
parce qu'ils voulaient je ne sais même
bien mieux que je sais qu'on va savoir
pourquoi c'est ça vous dit à un moment
je veux rester absolument debout parce
que si je me trouve
si je me mets à terre j'ai peur de plus
jamais relevé vous avez eu très très
peur a eu très très peur
ah oui parce que je sais que je il ne
faut pas rendre des coups et je sais
qu'il faut que les enquêtes
ça fait mal mais des coups de matraque
des coups de rangers dans les tibias
vous recevrez plus de vingt coups de
poing des coups de pied ont cinq minutes
des coups de genou de matraque vous fait
étranglée je veux pas qu'on confonde les
choses c'est à dire que j'ai été agressé
par trois personnes
je moi je crois en la justice je crois
en notre police est et je veux pas qu'on
confonde vraiment ces trois personnes là
pour moi en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne ne sont pas dignes d'eux
c'est des gens qui doivent me protéger
joint en uniforme c'est censé nous
protéger sa part été le cas je veux
vraiment con con ce qu'on remarque qu'on
se dise pas que kim et tous les
policiers dans le dans le même bateau
même se rentrait pas dans une des
policiers de la police de la gendarmerie
des forces de l'ordre c'est encore une
fois des brebis galeuses comme on les
appelle lui à l'ona dans tous les
métiers
[Musique]